I'll tell you a story about a class I  was teaching a few years ago this fellow  at the back raises his hand and he says  can I ask you a question he was in his  graduating year of engineering and he  had designed a compliance cloud-based  platform for hedge funds of 250 million  and under the Run rate was five million  dollars of free cash flow a year while  he was in his dorm he says to me my  girlfriend came to me today and said I  have to make a decision I said what's  the decision well we're engaged but she  doesn't want to live this way I have no  time for her family I have no time for  her I work every weekend I work all  night what do I do I don't want to lose  her and now the classes could have heard  a pin drop I said listen let's be  pragmatic about this which one is easier  to replace your business or your fiancee